I'm told you like to collect things
you're bit of a collector yeah I guess
you could call it that
but what kind of stuff are we talking
about rare coins mostly like things that
are similar to trash I guess you could
say like I collect a lot of coconut
husks like spent coconut houses what
well someday I'm gonna make like a
little planners with them like put a
little plant in the coconut husk oh is
that really the kind of stuff that you
yeah I got that and like I cooked on a
record so that's legit a lot of ton of
Records but those are like creating a
walkway problem in the house because I
have so many of them I cooked a lot of
pieces of wood I can find a piece of
wood outside I'm straight you will just
find wood lying around and you'll pick
it up and you'll say I could use this
maybe someday
well not like any wood like a good piece
of wood like maybe like a nice big stick
Nick Offerman just out here is an expert
craftsman right he can make anything are
you good making stuff with wood I'm good
at bringing it home and putting it next
to the TV that's what I like a nice good
let's see it's got like a little bit of
likes maybe a fork in it
yeah interest you have a lot of these
things in your house yeah so you're a
hoarder it's basically what you're
saying I could say it's more like a
depression-era sort of thing right yeah
right hoarding things really aren't much
of value yeah you can get something free
I'm AB love for you things how real that
happens in show business and showiness
they will give you free stuff have you
noticed that I love I love all the gift
bags and things like that I mean I don't
have use for almost anything like that
comes in the bags I just take it cause
it's free I'll take as many as I can get
if I can I love it like this show is
great because you guys gave us a bunch
of free give a bunch of free gifts in
the green room that's so nice actually
brought them out here this is so nice
you guys
yeah to give us all these gifts we give
some stuff out yeah we have some stuff
in there in the dressing room it's great
you guys gave me this nice full of lots
of pop yeah Garrett's popcorn that all
the guests get Garrett's Pappas it's
great I can pry you BRE use that tin for
something later yeah
I think it's pretty cool what else is in
here something good I got this mug Kona
mug yeah we give those out yeah it
should be a great read gifting thing
this Christmas and the green room had so
much great gifts this light bulbs oh
that's great no that's yeah that's just
like oh I said this is the real Jim this
[Applause]
here enjoy your I've been looking for
one this size to fit between the toilet
in the wall this is so perfect gonna be
good for you
you